so kann antimaterie erzeugt werden
russische forscher haben das rätsel
gelöst theoretisch jetzt in science
fiction forscher der russischen akademie
der wissenschaftler haben einen neuen
und relativ simplen weg gefunden
antimaterie zu erzeugen zumindest in der
theorie einen kleinen haken gibt es noch
aber was genau versteht man unter
antimaterie was macht sie so besonders
die uns bekannte materie ist ja das was
er um und sehen wahrnehmen die uns
alltäglich umgibt sie besteht aus
protonen elektronen und gegebenenfalls
auch aus neutrum protonen sind positiv
und elektronen negativ geladen das
neutron besitzt im gegensatz dazu keine
ladung bei der antimaterie ist das genau
andersherum die antiprotonen sind
negativ geladen und die elektronen
heißen positronen und sind positiv
geladen das neutron ist hier ein anti
neutron es besitzt allerdings immer noch
keine ladung der unterschied zum neutron
besteht darin dass es aus anti quarks
zusammengesetzt ist und nicht aus crocs
antimaterie ist übrigens auch die ganze
zeit um uns herum wir nehmen sie nur so
direkt nicht wahr kosmische strahlung
zum beispiel besteht zu einem sehr
kleinen teil aus antimaterie bevor wir
zur antimaterie produktion kommen klären
wir erstmal wie materie vom menschen
erzeugt werden kann der physiker oliver
pack und seine kollegen vom imperial
college in london haben im jahr 2014 ein
experiment durchgeführt bei dem aus
licht materie erzeugt werden konnte
sie bestätigten damit die theorie von
gregory breit und john biehl aus dem
jahr 1934 die vorhergesagt hatten
dass die kollision von zwei photonen ein
elektron und ein positron entstehen
lässt eigentlich hat oliver pack damit
sowohl ein teil von materie als auch
einen teil der antimaterie erzeugt das
positron ist in seinem versuch
allerdings so instabil dass es direkt
verschwindet ein stabileres gegenstück
der materie als antimaterie lässt sich
aber mittlerweile schon seit jahren
künstlich erzeugen und zwar mit einem
teilchenbeschleuniger
der prozess ist allerdings sehr
kostenintensiv und aufwendig dazu kommt
noch dass die resultate eines solchen
prozesses meist nicht sehr ergiebig sind
bislang konnte so nur sehr sehr wenig
und immer noch äußerst kurzlebige
antimaterie erzeugt werden das soll sich
jetzt aber ändern
igor kostin kopf und je generisch haben
einen neuen weg gefunden stabilere
antimaterie zu erzeugen das licht ist
wie auch im jahr 2014 gebündeltes und
äußerst energiereiches licht also ein
leser ein laserstrahl mit einer leistung
von etwa einer quadrille watt pro
quadratzentimeter würde so die forscher
auf metallfolien effekte der
quantenelektrodynamik kuscu idee
auslösen die energie mit der der leser
auf das metall schießt bringen die
elektronen im inneren der folie zum
strahlen
genauer gesagt würden gammastrahlen
photon freigesetzt werden und dann nehme
die kettenreaktion ihren alles
entscheidenden verlauf den
wissenschaftlern zufolge entfallen
nämlich die gammastrahlen protonen
elektronen und positronen die in ihren
berechnungen entstandenen positronen
wären in einem solch starken leser fällt
zudem auch noch sehr viel länger haltbar
als die bisher erzeugten positionen mit
der erzeugten antimaterie könnten
gewaltige energien freigesetzt werden
denn die animation der zusammenstoß von
materie und antimaterie kann theoretisch
100 mal so viel energie freisetzen wie
die die bei einer einzigen kernfusion
freigesetzt wird
jetzt muss ich aber leider allerdings
enttäuschen so fertig konzipiert das
ganze verfahren klingt so schlecht ist
es aktuell in der praxis umsetzbar
genauer gesagt das ganze verfahren
beruht lediglich auf einer simulation
derart leistungsstarke leser gibt es
zwar die können aber aktuell nur für
sehr kurze zeit ihre leistung aufrecht
erhalten besonders langlebig während die
positionen also mal wieder nicht wenn
euch das video gefallen hat dann lass
mir gerne einen daumen nach oben da und
natürlich ein kostenloses abo einfach
hier klicken
und wenn er hier klickt vergleichen
seite kommt ihr zu einem weiteren video
in dem wir uns mit einer weitere materie
der dunklen materie beschäftigen sehr
spannend und was glaubt ihr wie sie ein
bahnbrechendes neues verfahren stehen
wir vor einem durchbruch und unserer
energieprobleme sind bald gelöst
schreibt mir eure vorschläge und
meinungen in die kommentare und viel
spaß beim video und bis dann bleibt dran